[Musique]
alors que Katy Perry se produisait lundi
soir à Las Vegas
son concert a surtout été marqué par ce
moment
pendant de longues secondes la chanteuse
semble souffrir d'un problème oculaire
et tant d'ouvrir son œil droit en vain
simple mise en scène et fait du vaccin
beaucoup de fans s'interrogent et
certains se montrent même très inquiets
que se passe-t-il avec l'oeil de Katy
Perry là franchement ça craint devenu
viral cette vidéo a été vu plusieurs
millions de fois et on rappelle une
autre celle de Justin Bieber c'est
complètement paralysé de ce côté de mon
visage incompréhension et vidéo choc
autour de Katy Perry et Justin Bieber
atteint de paralysie faciale que se
passe-t-il
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il et merci d'être avec
nous professeur vous êtes Jean-jacques
jeanbrovski médecin hospitalier
spécialiste en médecine interne
professeur merci d'être là c'est
vraiment c'est un honneur pour nous
soyez la soif c'est un très grand
professeur monsieur jean-barovski et
c'est vrai que vous allez nous parler de
ça qu'est-ce que c'est quoi une
paralysie faciale j'ai vu des des
personnes qui me disaient oui ça peut
arriver voilà des paralysies faciales
voilà temporaire ça peut arriver mais
pas aussi bref que ce Katy Perry parce
que ce qu'elle a eu ça a duré à peine
quelques secondes d'accord et si c'était
nouveau par exemple et au vaccin elle en
aurait pas parlé déjà il y a une
demi-douzaine d'années
dans dans la presse donc la paralysie
faciale ça existe des paralysies
faciales temporaires et brève ça existe
en fait en médecine c'est ça que
sympathique c'est que tout existe et
même le contraire c'est ça alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle a eu Katy Perry c'est
difficile à diagnostiquer comme ça vu de
loin quand on va simplement la séquence
on voit effectivement on voit ici sur
les photos derrière vous pendant un
temps elle a déclaré en 2016 à un
candidat dans American Idol qu'elle
cachait son œil avec des chapeaux à
cause d'une ambiopie l'ambyopie c'est
une maladie qu'on voit chez les jeunes
enfants dans laquelle il y a un défaut
de communication entre les yeux et le
cerveau bon elle a dit ça en 2016 en
2021 elle a parlé de son œil paresseux
donc bien avant que le vaccin soit en
cause
encore une fois tout peut arriver et son
contraire aussi parce qu'il y a Justin
Bieber aussi on a vu un qui souffre du
syndrome de Ramsay Hunt s'agit d'un
trouble Renault neurologie rare
paralysant à côté du visage et lui aussi
aurait évoqué peut-être le fait de cette
vacciner alors le syndrome de Ramzan
dont on l'appelle pas comme ça en
français c'est son nom américain en
français on l'appelle syndrome de Sicard
qui est du nom du professeur français
qui en a parlé mais mais c'est
effectivement une maladie qui est liée
au virus varicelle herpès zona qui n'est
pas du tout
avec le covid rien et c'est
effectivement une maladie infectieuse
très rare c'est un zona et en fait les
gens qui ont ce syndrome de ramsehen ou
de Sicard ils ont un zona avec une
attaque ophtalmique qui ne dure pas une
fraction de seconde pendant le temps
qu'ils ont la poussée de maladie et bien
ils ont des lésions qui sont visibles à
l'œil nu rien à voir avec le vaccin
rigoureusement alors il y en a une qui
ne croit pas du tout ce que vous dites
c'est Béatrice Rosen elle a le droit de
croire
malgré les explications médicales il y a
beaucoup de gens qui disent c'est un
grand professeur peut-être non mais
c'est vrai bien sûr mais malgré les
toutes les explications il y a des gens
qui pensent quand même que ce sera à
cause du vaccin comme pour Justin Bieber
et ce qui pose question en fait avec
Katy Perry c'est que c'est une fervente
défenseur du vaccin elle s'était même
déguisée en vaccin pour Halloween pour
inciter les gens à se faire vacciner et
le fait qu'elle ne réagisse pas c'est
vrai que ça pose question et on se dit
que si elle était des défenseurs du
vaccin qu'elle est qu'elle voulait nier
l'aurait fait c'est ce que disent les
gens je pense que c'est à cause du covid
qui a parlé effectivement qui a promu le
vaccin l'incident a quelques secondes
alors évidemment dans une vidéo qui est
devenue virale on montre à loisir cette
cet épisode qui a duré en fait quelques
secondes à peine et elle a dit taper
fort dans vos mains faites beaucoup de
bruit comme on sait le faire sur un
plateau de télévision et puis le temps
que elle est finie de dire ça son œil
avait repris sa forme normale on a aussi
parlé d'autres hypothèses qui étaient
liées à ces fossiles associés à cela ça
n'a rigoureusement rien à voir d'un côté
elle s'est fait vacciner comme des
millions de gens des dizaines de
millions de gens peut-être des milliards
de gens et d'un autre côté elle a eu un
effet indésirable qui n'est un incident
qui a rien à voir avec la vaccination
en fait moi ce qui me dérange c'est que
vous êtes sûr de vous que c'est pas ça
au lieu de peut-être dire on sait pas
parce que il y a eu quand même des cas
qui ont été liés il y a eu des de la
pharmacovis vigilance il y a des effets
secondaires qui ont été il y a certes
donc là sur ces cas-là précis évidemment
on peut pas affirmer que c'est ça ou
c'est pas ça mais en fait ce qui me gêne
c'est que c'est toujours circuler il y a
rien à voir et c'est sûr que c'est pas
ça c'est tout sauf ça et en fait c'est
ça je pense qui et même je pense que
c'est contre-productif dans l'opinion
publique parce que on sait que tout peut
avoir des effets secondaires donc
pourquoi en 2016
indépendamment du fait qu'elle avait
déjà la même chose en 2016 ou en 2021
là-dessus en 2016
indépendamment du fait que la communiqué
dessus à deux reprises indépendamment de
ça on connaît les effets indésirables
qui ont été attribués aux concomitant à
la vaccination d'ailleurs en général
avec les vaccins de première génération
qui n'étaient pas des vaccins ARN
modifié comme on a maintenant les les
effets secondaires répertoriés sur tous
sur la pharmacologie
bien entendu les effets secondaires je
vais vous dire parce que comme je savais
que quelqu'un poserait la question tu
mets faction des paupières ce n'est pas
ça légion pure purique aux paupières
neurotinopathie maculaire
aiguës de déclarations faisant l'état de
symptomoculaires seulement comme vision
trouble et douleurs oculaires alors
c'est quoi rien de tout ça rien de
problème
mais rien à voir avec la fermeture d'une
paupière pendant 3 secondes rien donc
c'est quoi ça sert à rien ça c'est mais
on doit s'inquiéter
qui est d'autant plus gênant qu'elle se
produit à télévision tout le monde en
tout le monde en convient de là à faire
une relation avec telle ou tel truc elle
aurait pu boire un soda et avoir le même
effet on aurait dit c'est le soda alors
ça jusqu'à plus
il y a pas de raison de s'inquiéter pour
eux si j'étais je ferai vérifier que
effectivement il y a pas de quoi
s'inquiéter mais elle va pas périr Cathy
pour tous ces fans pour tous ces fans
dieu merci non non mais attendez ça n'a
duré encore une fois si vous regardez la
séquence parce que je suis allé à la
chair alors on va la voir regardez si
vous la regardez en totalité ah ouais
alors elle essaie de le rouvrir
elle a pu comme ça elle avait un bouton
de vous le dire mais une paralysie c'est
pas ça je vous dis je parle pas de ce
cas précisé dans la semaine non mais si
on déconne merci
qui ont été rapportés suite
concomitante
donc on ne sait pas on peut pas dire
qu'on sait avec certitude que c'est pas
mal tout est vrai et même son contraire
[Applaudissements]